well you would think the big headline
news in the world today would be that
the stock market is recovering but it's
not that's not the headline news I
thought it was I thought the fact that
the world was not coming to an end
officially this week was probably going
to be headline news but no James child's
our producer lays the headline news on
my desk for me New York couple spends
thirty thousand dollars to save cat's
life yeah you got this from sale you're
handing the blame off okay how far would
you go the article says to save your
pets life a buffalo couple traveled more
than 400 miles and spent around $30,000
so their cat okie could receive a
life-saving operation eleven-year-old
okie recently had a kidney transplant at
the University of Pennsylvania
veterinary hospital the new kidney is
expected to give him at least another
three years to live ten thousand a year
I am a trois that quickly but the
life-saving measure came with a little
something extra
okay new kidney was donated by another
cat two year old cherry the couple had
to adopt cherry in order to get the
healthy kidney
now both cherry and okie are recouping
in their Buffalo home after a grueling
eight hour surgery less than a week ago
the money owners Andrey and Lori spent
on the operation the money that they
spent on the operation would have gone
towards a down payment on a house if
buying a house would have actually meant
to lose someone that we both love so
much living in that house would have
been wrong Andre told News four Okies
medicine will cost thousands more so why
did the couple do it Andre told News 4
oki is like a son to him he rescued him
as a kitten in Romania so 30 thousand
dollars I mean I would understand if it
was a dog but it was a cat
oh I'm sorry cat lovers I'm messing with
you don't get all serious and start
tweeting me hate mail and putting bombs
in my mailbox again you kept people or
angry people um no we don't I'm just
kidding with you but does that not this
not just blow your mind I mean I'm an
animal lover and I have the money to
spend $30,000 on an animal likelihood
though of that animal making it is
pretty slim um if $30,000 is the
requirement I just make a distinction
between animals and humans I've got a my
little buddy Rufus my little Shih Tzu
was up in my lap this morning jumping
all over me while I'm drinking my coffee
spilling coffee on me and we love our
little you know em Maggie Maggie the
golden retriever jumps off the dock and
will retrieve every piece of driftwood
out of the lake and deposited on my lawn
we love Maggie Maggie skis with me we
love our dogs they're part of our family
30,000 bucks it ain't happening they're
dogs and some of you're going to send me
hate mail for that I'm just sayin it's
okay this is the Dave Ramsey show and
I'm an expert on my opinion and so
that's you know I get it I mean I
understand people love their pets and I
love love animals I do I truly do I'm an
animal nut I just um most animals anyway
some animals I'm not wild about but I
mean a little cat I guess is okay if
you're a cat person I'm not a cat person
but um 30,000 bucks instead of buying a
house I what yeah what scares me is that
you have a vote that's what scares me
you get to vote they allow you to oh god
Oh lack of common sense I I don't know
at you know part of the problem too is
I'm south of the mason-dixon line and
some of you are West
the Mississippi and if you're south of
the mason-dixon line and/or west of the
Mississippi you likely have been around
a farm at least a little at some time in
your life Buffalo New York
not so much I get that but I mean if you
grew up around a farm cats are kind of
out a dime a dozen they come they go you
don't really even notice they're just
kind of around where's that when we
hadn't seen that one in a couple of
weeks you know it's just that's kind of
the farm cat deal you know it's a little
different I guess than a house cat but
uh and dogs and I mean animals come and
go they do uh but I mean I'm kind of
worried about me I mean we had a friend
the other day that passed away that was
in their 80s and my wife bless her heart
she's usually pretty compassion her
comment was well they were old and I'm
idea is that what you're gonna say about
me you're just gonna like let me go he
was old it's okay it's no big deal
he made it awhile I'm I'm worried about
me and not $30,000 for a cat I'm
concerned I told the kids to watch their
mother because I'm kind of scared now um
so yeah I mean cat ain't got a chance
with Sharon I'll just tell you that she
grew up on the farm there's no chance
the dog either one she's actually
threatened for some of ours to run away
remembers that Jeff Foxworthy routine
when we were growing up we had animals
and you know the cat would tear down
Mama's curtains and the next day the cat
ran away y'all remember that or the dog
that tore up the neighbors whatever and
the next day that dog ran away it was
amazing the correlation between the
misbehavior of the animal and them
running away shortly thereafter um so
it's a little different than $30,000 for
okie to get a kidney hmm okay you are
one blessed cat I'll tell you that buddy
well you got traded a kidney for a house
a cat kidney for a house cat kidney
house cat kidney house mmm wrong choice
okay
sorry y'all but I just had to start out
the day with a little just to remind you
that part of what happens on this show
is after listening this show you just
feel smart some of the people that call
in with some of the things you do you
walk away going I'm smart and
that you know those of you that sold out
your 401k yesterday because the world's
coming to an end and somebody told you
that on a fictional novel and so you're
completely in freakout mode now compared
to the $30,000 cap people you feel smart
see so both of your done but you feel
smart so yeah it was dumb I mean I again
all the caveats aside and all that and I
understand and I'm a cat lover and I'm
not I'm not mean I'm an animal lover and
and I'm not greedy and I'm not hateful
and I'm not nasty or mean but thirty
thousand dollars save a cat come on I
mean now Leona Helmsley however you
remember her she was the hotel lady in
New York passed away and she left like a
million dollars or something for the
care of her puppy which probably had
three years left to live - that's the
other thing three years left to live so
it's already an old cat oh sorry on it's
just you know stuff like that I read
that we will always have a show because
there always be people needing financial
help as long as there are people that
this is the tech privacy show